[Music]
hello and welcome to justice my judge
Jeanine Pirro
thanks so much for being with us tonight
and thank you so much for giving justice
a huge audience with more than three
million plus viewers last Saturday so
tonight as we gear up for Super Bowl
Sunday let's go for another big score
and on the field to help us get there
tonight
our Republican Congressman Jim Jordan
mark meadows and Doug Collins as well as
Senator Tom cotton Kimberly Strauss old
from The Wall Street Journal and a
little later on my one-on-one exclusive
with Trump campaign manager Brad parse
Cal plus we take you live to Miami to
talk all things Super Bowl on this eve
of the big game with Fox Nations Casey
McDonald it's all coming up but first my
open I want to take this opportunity to
thank our friends specifically Democrats
Nancy Pelosi Adam Schiff Jerry Nadler
and the whole unhinged a lot of them for
guaranteeing the re-election of
President Donald John Trump in 2020
their nonstop hate hypocrisy and
hysteria has so exhausted us that we
honestly can't wait to reelect him again
their political stunts have been a
colossal waste of time and have sealed
his reelection
although technically it hasn't happened
yet his acquittal in the Senate is a
foregone conclusion delayed yet again
and you senators had to drag this out
until next week and couldn't work
through the weekend why now I keep
asking myself why these Democrats keep
making liars and fools of themselves
the president is a Russian asset no says
Robert Muller the president is the
illegitimate occupier of the Oval no
says the Electoral College the president
is as described in the dossier no says
the chief judge of the FISA Court
as well as a Department of Justice the
president is a racist no says
african-american unemployment and Ben
Carson's Opportunity Zones the president
will ruin the economy no says the stock
market over and over and over again and
the latest Ukraine claim no says the
best evidence the real evidence the
transcript an Adam Schiff says the
president's misconduct cannot be decided
at the ballot box because quote we
cannot be assured the vote will be
fairly won Adam are you stupid or do you
think we are
aren't you guys embarrassed yet why the
democrat party allegedly the party of
inclusion and openness is at this moment
in time the most obstructive a mutinous
non-productive
rebellious group of haters the party has
ever seen can only be attributed to
their trump derangement syndrome as he
is only occupying space going there
running there like a bunch of thugs
ganging up to destroy and remove the
president hate is their crusade
overthrow is their mantra and they use
impeachment to overturn the will and the
election of the american people
[Music]
the funny thing is they call President
Trump a monarch a dictator a fascist but
they do exactly what they accused the
president of doing every day and they
have the hutzpah to complain about the
Senate trial when they brought their
case in a star chamber they turn
American jurisprudence upside down
saying the president's claim of
executive privilege is proof of his
guilt when the whole point of executive
privilege is to protect the Constitution
and the separation of powers and they
look like fools fighting to get to the
camera first to get as much face time as
possible
watch shift try to pull back Nadler any
other comments the Senate would benefit
from hearing before we adjourn for the
evening mr. Chief Justice members of the
Senate you know I think I want a
moratorium on the I word I'm so over
talking about impeachment and I'll bet
you are too I don't ever want to have to
mention it again but it won't be over on
Wednesday they're gonna do it again
they'll find another make-believe
whistleblower or another foreign agent
that they'll pay to make up lies about
our president so I say to myself self
what are these fools doing in Congress
they could care less about us about
immigration or heroin coming through the
southern borders or the fact that they
held back the u.s. MCA for months
because they didn't want to give
President Trump a win they can't even
give the president credit for taking out
two of the world's worst terrorists in a
matter of weeks with no collateral
damage military's rebuilt the economy is
soaring unemployment at an all-time
low so I guess I'll just end it where I
started I want to thank our friends the
Democrats for taking off their masks and
exposing their hate their condescension
and their disgust for the rest of us I
also want to thank the Democrats for
uniting the Republican Party except
permit we didn't want mid anyway and I
want to thank Donald Trump not only for
teaching the Republicans finally how to
fight but for putting up with the
nonsense that he goes through every day
for the rest of us to make America great
and that's my open let me know what you
think on my Facebook and Twitter hashtag
judge Jeanine